new infections are accelerating around
the world
in what appears to be the pandemic's
next wave
but even as death rates remain lower in
hot spots
health officials say it's too soon to
assume mortality rates won't tick up
alongside case counts
the fall winter search continues to
unfold in europe
with exponential increases in daily
cases
and matching percentage increases in
daily
debts the evolving epidemiological
situation in europe
raises great concern as they look at the
surging numbers
one expression is uniting many
scientists
they're calling this time a cliffhanger
moment
what can the figures tell us about the
best way to respond
[Music]
welcome to dw's 19 special i'm janelle
dumalaon
we find ourselves in a time where each
day seems to bring new
sobering infection records governments
everywhere are trying to push those
numbers down while trying to stave off
full lockdowns
but few have been able to avoid new
restrictions
we bring you this report from france
lunchtime in the era of coronavirus the
last time
emma finney had fries she shared them
with a friend who later tested positive
for kovit 19.
emma then ventured a temporary testing
center close to a university here in
sergi
not far from paris but she never
received her results
it was annoying because all of my
friends were meeting at like apartments
or anything to just like
live and i couldn't even go to school
to uh like attend the class physically
when i called so it was really like
boring to just stay home and do nothing
but i think you have to go through that
it's not usual for test results to get
lost in france
but waiting for them isn't unusual
recently people here often had to sit
tight for several days
in some cases over a week to get an
appointment
and the result time during which many
others
could have been infected france was hit
especially hard in the spring
at the beginning of the covet 19
pandemic that's why the country ramped
up tests
and is now carrying out more than one
million per week
like in this lab led by jean-jacques
jimenez
he says the situation has improved
given the fact that the requests were
twice as high
we had to make sure that we could
technically carry out the number of
tests requested
another
today this situation is currently being
resolved
but rapid testing is not the only
solution
cases are especially high in big cities
like paris
where the density of population is very
high
this hospital in pontoise north of paris
was going through a hard time during the
first wave
eduard devoe is coordinating the kovit
19 response here
he sees another main reason for the rise
in numbers in france
the french population suffered a huge
trauma during the first wave
nevertheless with another wave we're
seeing a relative luxe behavior in
people
divorces personal responsibility is key
in fighting the virus
keeping a safe distance and meeting as
few people as possible
but since the virus is now heavily
circulating in france
the government is toughening rules in
paris for example
bars have to close down for now
we're joined now by katarina fenn she's
a lead data scientist at the world data
lab
katarina since the start of the pandemic
we've been inundated with numbers and it
can be hard to derive meaning from them
we've seen the death toll from
coronavirus worldwide past
1 million now what does a figure like
that tell us
well first of all i think it tells us
that we should really take this
challenge of this disease seriously i
mean one million is quite a high number
and i think that a few months ago we
would not really have been able to
imagine this
but to really derive meaning from the
numbers
and to really stand for setting measures
i think it's even more important to look
at country specific numbers
and especially country specific numbers
of deaths
and i think still always all these
numbers um this pandemic
really puts us into a new situation and
it's a really new challenge
and still we don't really know how the
next month will turn out
but why is it most important to get
country specific numbers and especially
of deaths does how does that help us get
the most accurate picture of the impact
of the pandemic
so first of all i think if we look at
the number of infections versus the
number of deaths
the numbers of infections obviously
depend a lot on how much do we
retest and the numbers of deaths
i think they are better reported in
almost every country of the world so i
think they give us a better picture of
what is actually happening and how bad
the situation really is
i think however it can make sense to
look at the number of infections
if we think about short-term measures
that we want to take and then the number
of infections gives us a better picture
but otherwise and especially if we want
to compare different countries across
the world
i think the number of that gives us an
even better picture
now comparisons have also figured quite
prominently people would say compare
flu deaths to coronavirus deaths as a
way of putting
these numbers into context how useful do
you think that
is as an exercise
well i think if we compare the numbers
of decks
this can also actually be quite
misleading if we compare
kovid 19 to the normal fuel i think that
in a lot of countries we can see that
the numbers of
decks from kovite 19 are not so high so
far like for example in germany or
austria but we had
the chance to really take measures quite
early in this pandemic
but i think um here we should not be
misled by the numbers of deaths
but we should rather look at studies
that analyze the infection fatality rate
so this is basically the rate
of how many people who are infected no
matter whether they show
symptoms or not really die of this
disease
and here we can see that covid19 is
actually 16 times as deadly
as the normal flu so i think that's the
better comparison here
16 times as deadly as a normal flu that
is a staggering figure of course
i also wanted to ask you about the
number of unreported cases we have to
assume they're a lot
how much do you think they affect our
understanding of the whole picture
well they definitely affect our
understanding of this picture and it's
really hard to assess
also how many unreported cases they are
especially in countries that either do
not really
want to test a lot or also in poor
countries that just don't have the
possibility to really get
good measures of these numbers i think
in this case it can be helpful to look
at the total numbers of deaths
not only from kovitt but all over all
and in the whole country
and then compare these numbers to the
averages from the last years
and i think this can really tell us have
the has the number of deaths increased
have
people been dying because of this
pandemic
now i have to say katrina i worry that
we lose sight of the fact that behind
these numbers
there are real people and real
consequences for real lives
to your mind are policy makers doing a
good job
of remembering this when they design
responses to the crisis
well i want to assume that they are
doing their best
and i think that in many countries also
for example germany and austria
they have done a quite a good job so far
i mean i think it's really hard
to assess which masters measures we
should take and i really wouldn't want
to be in their place so
i think in many countries they are doing
a rather good job so far
also i think that um
the numbers are probably the most useful
tool
for setting measures and for strategic
planning so
i think numbers and data really give us
the best guideline here
and i think that um as com as opposed to
like emotions or
the feelings that we have with these
pandemic numbers
can also really help us to fight the
misinformation and also the insecurity
that is related to
this pandemic so i think that looking at
the numbers
and really trying to do our best with
setting different measures here is the
best we can do at the moment
numbers tell a story but you have to be
listening thank you very much katrina
fence of the world data lab we really
appreciate your insights
thank you for having me and speaking of
numbers here are the latest data from
more than 200 countries
the numbers show new cases doubling in
38 nations
and increasing in another 79 countries
they've stayed at the same level in 10
countries
67 nations have seen their new positive
covet 19 cases decline
another eight are down by at least half
and
eight countries have reported no new
cases for four weeks in a row
here's the bar graph showing the
statistics of the past few weeks
the fight against the coronavirus will
be over when that whole
chart turns blue so it's going to take
some time
and now it's time for your questions
over to our science correspondent
derek williams
what's dangerous is the pneumonia why
not find a cure
or treatment for the pneumonia instead
of the virus
pneumonia is a blanket term that's
generally defined
as a more or less serious inflammation
of tissue
in your air passages and or your lungs
it can be caused by a number of
different pathogens both both viral
and bacterial um the pneumonia that
coven 19 can cause
is generally initiated by the virus
and can't be treated for example uh with
antibiotics
which only kill bacteria when they're
infected with sars cove 2
the cells in the small sacs in your
lungs where gas exchange occurs what are
called
um the alveoli begin to die
and clog the lungs up and and that can
eventually lead to what's called
acute respiratory distress syndrome
as the pneumonia progresses the
situation can be exacerbated
by the immune system causing massive
inflammation
which is which is supposed to help get
the infection under control but which
can actually make things worse
so so treating or curing coronavirus
pneumonia means
either addressing the problem at its
root which is the sars cove to
infection itself or somehow toning down
the body's immune response to it when it
goes
over the top